[Music]
wednesdays to talk about what quantum
computers are how people are building
them what they can do what they can't do
they're not all-powerful godlike devices
so they do have limitations that will
we'll get into as well okay without
further ado let me introduce our
esteemed panelists our first panelist is
a mathematician computer scientist
physicist expert on quantum information
theory she was a professor at tel aviv
university and a researcher at the CNRS
in paris please welcome Julie Efendi our
next participant is the professor of
quantum mechanical engineering that's a
thing at MIT director of the Keck Center
for extreme quantum information theory
and hopefully will explain why it's
extreme to us please welcome Seth Lloyd
next up our next guest comes to us from
the air force research laboratory in
Rome in upstate New York
she's a senior research scientist there
and the primary investigator for the
trapped ion quantum networking group
please welcome Kathy on Soderberg
and finally coming to us from IBM in
Yorktown Heights just north of the city
is the manager of the experimental
quantum computing group distinguish the
research staff member of please welcome
Jerry chow
so chef let me turn to you first
quantum mechanics weird or just
unfamiliar definitely weird it's a I
think I prefer the word funky actually
okay it's a James Brown of Sciences so
how so I mean why and in particularly in
terms of computation what is it what's a
special quality of quantum physics so in
in quantum mechanics things that we
think of as being like particles like
basketballs or soccer balls have waves
that are attached to them and so you
know I put this ball over here and it's
got a wave and then like have the ball
over here has got a wave but the funky
thing about that is that the waves can
add up so I can have a ball that's both
here and there at the same time and if
you map this to a bit in a quantum
computer so this is zero ball over here
ball over there is one then I can have a
quantum bit or qubit that's zero and one
at the same time so Julia why would that
be someone would actually want why would
this I mean I want to actually comment
on the weird first if I'm a funky funky
because I think it becomes it depends on
your point of view are coming at it as a
physicist with a lot of training in
classical physics it's indeed probably
very weird but if you look at it as a
computer scientist it maybe becomes less
weird because we are not spoiled our
intuition is still is is not how can I
say a biased in any way and I view it as
something which is like probability
theory except the probabilities can be
negative or they can be even complex but
that that is not so essential and so in
that sense it's it's not very weird it's
just gets a it requires a bit of getting
used to but it's pretty natural and so
for the qubits why is it useful to have
qubits in being both 0 and 1 at the same
time because if we have many of the
we can think of having various states at
the same time and we can think of
computing all these possibilities at the
same time so that leads us to this
massive what's called quantum
parallelism so Jerry can you walk me
through it like a nuke just known to
quit numeric example of you if you have
certain number of qubits what that means
in terms of parallelism yeah so I mean
what are the well as has been mentioned
with regard to these cubes you have
these super positions and so you might
have some number of bits but instead of
bits now you have qubits right and in
terms of the this parallelism what you
can actually have is access to a much
larger space of possibilities so if you
have n qubits you actually have using
these principles of superposition and
entanglement you have access to a space
of up to 2 to the N possibilities and so
that type of that type of exponential
space gets really really large for
rather modest numbers of qubits in fact
if you get to around n of three hundred
qubits you actually have some state
space that is greater than the total
number of particles in our universe
Kathy Ann walked through an extremely
simple numerical example suppose I in
fact we do have but to take an example
two of these qubits what does that mean
in terms of the computational space that
we so if you have two qubits you have a
four qubit state space because you can
have each one stored as a zero plus one
and the other one stores is your plus
one so you get 0 0 0 1 1 0 1 1
whereas classically you could only have
0 or 1 you can't have anything in
between
so if computers in a sense in all
possible computational state said yes
that's right no stuff on the face of it
that doesn't sound like such a good idea
because you want to get an answer from
the computer and it's just basically
telling you everything yeah it's a kind
of dangerous if I have a quantum bit
that's 0 and 1 at the same time and I
say yo ru01 well I mean no you okay so
it's an electron it's either here or and
I bring up a very sensitive
electrometers it says yo are you here or
there well it's either gonna show up
here say with 50% probability or there
with 50% probability so it's just going
to behave like something that's
generating a random number which is kind
of useful but
manat if you actually want certainty for
your answers it's not so great so the
kind of the way that these quantum
computations work you set up all these
waves and they're wiggling on top of
each other and they're there they're
performing multiple computations
simultaneously so you can think of an
individual wave a wave of say electron
here and not there that's kind of like a
pure tone like an electron here and not
there is like aa and electron here and
there at the same time is does somebody
want to apply and supply the other
target to do this looking scared it's a
core so it's it's you you get the
computational power from the
interference from the kind of symphonic
nature this so the idea of a quantum
computation you set up all these waves
they make this beautiful music together
in the symphonic way but at the end of
the day you actually want to have an
answer that says yes or no or 0 or 1 and
all the the the trickery and talent goes
into making that happen so Julia is that
any problem I care to pull out of a hat
or that my professors give me as a
homework assignment can I turn it into a
problem that's amenable to this kind of
chord pattern that then reduces to a
single pure tone and that might depend
on your artistry but in general quantum
computers are good at certain things and
we would leave you know a lot of other
things to a normal classical computer
and of course you've probably all heard
of the the problem that a quantum
computer can solve very well and that's
factoring numbers large very large
numbers into primes and the way it's
done just like Seth was saying and I was
saying you can think of these amplitudes
of a quantum computer as positive and
negative numbers we try to arrange these
waves in a way that all the bad answers
cancel out because if you can you know
you can have several ways to arrive at
the wrong answer and what you'll try is
have some with a positive amplitude and
some with a negative amplitude and they
cancel out and then you arrive at the
right answer and you voila you get a
factor for a very big number and that's
one of the first and most remarkable
things that was discovered
one computer can do and I can elaborate
on why it's important most of you all of
you I assume are using credit cards at
the machine or over the Internet and you
rely on the fact that their encryption
that they are encrypted and it so
happens that modern-day encryption is
based on assumptions of hardness of
factoring or problems of that type and
it's these type of problems that a
quantum computer would be able to easily
break interesting Oh Kathy let me ask
you drill down a little bit more here so
when I think of a computer I think of it
has those arithmetic logical operations
how do you I mean without going to
details we get to some of the details
later
but does the quantum computer also have
those same elements of it can add it can
subtract it can do logical comparisons
of things yes yes you need all the same
similar components to a classical
computer to do quantum computing but the
way that you you make the gates looks
very different than in a conventional
computer and that's somewhat depends on
the underlying qubit technology okay
tells on that later I just want to
stablish that it's a computer yes it has
you look at it and though it's
configured differently it does have the
recognizable qualities about computer
one additional instruction which says
take this clone a bit and put it here
and there at the same time put in the
state zero and one the same time so you
supplement an ordinary computer language
with just one additional quantum
instruction and you're good to go
accordingly if you can build the thing
of course Jerry what are we up to
deceits and general state of the art
about how many qubits we have and what
does that mean in terms of these would
be a classical machine yeah so there's
many different physical implementations
of building quantum computer the
underlying core of a quantum computer we
call a quantum processor and what you
basically need to build a quantum
processor is something that follows the
laws of quantum mechanics and can have
this quantum mechanical 0 and 1 and
terms of where we are in in experiments
we're looking at building Universal
based quantum computers of order of ten
to twenty cubits at the moment and
that's that's kind of where the state of
the art is in in the field and just for
reference sake 20 bits doesn't sound
like a lot actually but how does that
what kind of power does that end on the
machine with well that it's that's
actually very interesting is because
although you might have twenty cubits
you can actually then have this state
space of two to the twenty possibilities
right but how much you're actually able
to access that then to turn is
determined by your your coherence time
so that there's a metric known as
coherence time which says how how good
of a quantum state can you actually keep
in your quantum processor and different
types of technology is varying from
superconducting to trapped ions like
Kathy Anne works on have different
amounts of coherence time and so overall
this type of time times the number of
qubits we try to we try to at least my
colleagues at IBM we've started thinking
about a metric for this called quantum
volume to kind of describe what is the
power of a quantum computer so walk me
through what's a quantum volume it's you
can basically think of it as how many
steps of these logical operations are
these these gate operations that you can
do the superposition or entanglement
steps in the amount of time that before
all of the quantum information is gone
it becomes just classical and so you
have a certain number of steps and then
you have a certain amount of depth in
terms of the the total number of qubits
that are connected to one another so
Julia let me let me ask ask this of you
if I just have a my phone a classical
ordinary computer and I store
information in it one hopes at least the
computer will retain that for a long
period of time it's Jerry saying that
actually it decays away and why would it
do that inside a quantum computer so the
big challenge for a quantum computer is
indeed to maintain these coherences or
these waves that are spread over not
just you know one qubit but over the
collection of in this case perhaps
twenty cubits and what we call
entanglement these these
correlations at a distance of these
qubits and it is true that this is what
nature does on a very small scale when
we describe electrons and so on but it's
also true that we don't observe this in
our everyday life I mean when you have a
bit you have a bit it's either 0 or 1
and the reason we don't observe it is
that once we start interacting with the
environment what's once this very
fragile superposition is being subjected
to the surroundings it's being subject
to noise and these very fragile super
positions will start to what we call
decohere so just disappear and the point
is of course that we need to be able to
address this quantum computer we need to
be able to talk to it we need to be able
to manipulate it so it has to be exposed
to us to to our you know to the world in
that sense and so we're living in this
trade-off situation where on one hand we
need to protect the statement so we
would like to just put it in the fridge
and never touch it on the other end we
have to touch it in order to manipulate
it and this is the big challenge that
you know these experimentalists are
facing to battle this decoherence that
invariably comes along with the fact
that we're exposed to the you know to
the environment Kathy Ann you're walking
into your laboratory what would we see
and then walk me through what that
represents sure so I'll talk about trap
ion technology which is what we work on
and I'm to leave Jerry will talk about
superconducting qubits in a few minutes
they're they're very different
technologies but they're both very
advanced right now in the field so for 4
ions we trap single atoms and then we
hold them there their charge so you can
hold them using electric fields so first
we we prepare a vacuum chamber because
as you just heard these systems are very
fragile so you need to protect them from
the environment so these trapped ions
operate at room temperature but we hold
them in a vacuum chamber at roughly 10
to the minus twelfth Torr that's the
same vacuum as outer space so the only
thing in there is the atoms that you
want to manipulate and you have a
neutral atom source which is just a
piece of metal in a stainless steel oven
that you heat up and then that creates a
beam of neutral atoms which you can put
in your what's called an ion trap which
is just a collection of metal electrodes
because as I said we dropped these using
electric fields since they're charged so
you put an oscillating electric field on
that trap
and what that looks like to the atom is
a rotating saddle so then that looks
like a bowl and if you drop a marble in
a bowl eventually it'll come to rest at
the bottom of the bowl the trapped ions
do the exact same thing in these
potentials and so we shine the neutral
atom beam near the trap and then we have
a laser that actually rips one of the
electrons off the neutral atom and that
makes our ion
so that leaves it charged and at the
same time we have to shine a different
color of light in because coming
straight out of an oven the atoms are
essentially screaming hot and the Trop
potential just can't catch an atom
that's going that fast so you have to
cool it down a little bit with a laser
its laser coin and then that allows you
to trap it in this this bowl-like
potential and then we shine yet another
color of light on the the atom and all
these different colors of light create
different transitions within the atomic
structure so if you could look in the
atom you would see different energy
levels inside and each color of light is
resonant with a different energy level
and so the detection light when we shine
it on it hits a very strong transition
in the atom which excites it from its
its ground state so the qubits
themselves are held in the ground states
of these atoms there's two ground States
and it sends it to an excited state it's
a very short lift state and when it
emits it emits a photon and it does
since it's a strong transition it does
at hundreds of thousands of times and
then we collect those photons on a
camera the ion that we're using as you
terbium so it emits in the UV if it was
a visible color you could actually see
it with your eye it'd be a tiny speck
and we don't change see atoms you can
see atoms
yeah just like if you shine shine just
like when you shine a flashlight on a
ball in a dark room right it scatters
light and then your eyes can see it and
you say oh there's a ball sitting there
the atoms do the same thing they emit
tape emitted photons that if your eye
was visible to the UV you could see them
it would just be a tiny dot on a very
dark background you can see a single
atom fluorescing the darkest you know
the the brightest star in a very dark
sky unfortunately we can't see in the UV
with with our eyes so we have to use a
camera but if you were lucky into our
lab you would see large optical cables
that are about six feet long by four
feet wide
filled with lasers because to do all the
different operations you need different
frequencies of light and then you'd see
another vacuum chamber that hold or
their optical table excuse me that holds
our vacuum chambers okay so let me just
see if I follow yeah you load your your
system yes with your terbium ions yes
and to perform a computation just
example how do you clear the memory
we'll give you the first step in your
computation sure so uh usually you start
with some number let's say between 2 & 5
ions is what you would want so you load
2 or 5 ions let's say 2 for this example
so we can turn the oven on for a set
amount of time and we shine the laser
that takes ripsi elector enough to
create the ions and we wait till we get
2 ions and then we can see them on the
camera and so we initialize the system
to a zero state just like in
conventional competing you have to
initialize your computer to a zero state
and then if we wanted to put those two
ions in a superposition we could shine
either a laser or a microwave at them
and that would create a superposition so
you you could think of of qubits on on
what's called a block sphere which is
just a unit sphere where the up z-axis
could be your one qubit state and the
down z-axis could be your zero qubit
state so you're prepared in a zero and
then we shine these microwaves or lasers
on on the atoms and it causes the
population to rotate basically and so
you just stop when you get to the
Upstate and you can look at that it's a
trace on a scope so for example I mean a
standard operation simplest possible
operation you might have in a computer
system not that's right so how would you
do it or not
so yeah you would prepare you would
prepare your qubit in this gyro state
and then you would shine a microwave or
a laser beam on it for a set amount of
time and it would cause a population to
evolve to the to the Upstate and that's
a not gate if you go from zero to one
that's a not gate if I left that light
or microwave interactional and then it
would go back down to the zero state and
it would just keep rotating
so what's suppose I want to do something
a bit more sophisticated like an and or
something that actually combines two
qubits how would you how would you do
that yeah so if you had two qubits in
trapped ions the nice thing is that
because they're charged they want to
repel each other but because there's a
trapping potential on them they get
pushed together so they find a happy
medium where they they sit but they have
a shared emotional mode
due to this interaction so there are a
lot like a Newton's Cradle if you pull a
ball in a Newton's Cradle you see all
the balls move together yeah that's
right that's right
and so the trapped ions do the same
thing if you start to shine a laser beam
on one and you excite some motion and
actually excites motion in both ions and
so then you have a data bus that you can
get the ions to talk to each other and
if you had five ions you could actually
use this data bus to get one in five to
talk to each other directly so you're
not limited to nearest neighbor
interactions in the trapped ion system
and you can use that that's right and
then you can use that combine motional
mode to get the the qubit States to talk
to each other and create things like
controlled-not gates say so a jury can
you repeat that kind of virtuoso yes
I'll try my best there what's it like in
there actually yeah so our lab looks a
lot different from what what Kathy Ann
described and that that that the reason
for that is because the underlying qubit
is very different one difference that
the main difference is that instead of
actually having physical NAT naturally
occurring qubits in this case you
terbium ions that you can you know that
it's all of this work is based off of
having really really stable atomic
clocks what we're doing with with
superconducting qubits is to actually
engineer and build them on a chip so
it's a little more integrated you're
actually using with lithographic
techniques that you know and love today
with your silicon processors and instead
of the materials that are in your in
your in your chips that are in your
phone or your laptop we're using
slightly different materials to build
superconducting circuits so
superconducting refers to materials that
that when they're cold they have have
basically no resistance and by by using
the right kinds of superconductors you
can actually build quantum effects into
circuit elements so at the end the I
have a good picture for what the the bit
is the the ion is either pointing up or
you know rotating that direction that
corresponds door or the other way so
what's the corresponding yes so the way
the thing about it here is that you're
actually building
an oscillator circuit so if you if you
go back to your electric engineering
days think about the circuits that you
might build with resistors or capacitors
or inductors these are various circuit
elements in the case of a superintending
circuit you actually can use an element
known as a Josephson junction and a
Josephson junction is basically a
sandwich of aluminum aluminum oxide
aluminum and what's phenomenal about
this this element is that you can
combine it with a with the standard
capacitor and you can make an oscillator
in the microwave regime so around
five-year hertz and choosing the right
parameters of the capacitance and this
joseph's injunction you can isolate it
to build a qubit state so zero and one
that that resonates at around five years
so in your case can you walk through a
an example i'm how you load your
computer right so in this case memory in
this case where we have a silicon
fabrication facility that builds these
circuits we they come out in large wafer
form and then we have to cut them up
into smaller chips these chips are
packaged into a printed circuit board
like what you might see in in the inside
your phone but this printed circuit
board carries microwave signals and so
those the the the printed circuit board
then needs to be cooled down to really
really low temperatures to basically
have the the Cubist function properly
so i said that we use these super
connecting materials and so the
materials are now Veeam in aluminum and
and for them to superconduct and for
there to be so little noise that we can
actually see these quantum mechanical
effects at 5 gigahertz we need to cool
down to 15 milli Kelvin so that's since
you already brought the space analogies
colder than outer space as well and in
fact you know with the microwave
background in space is around it's a
little under 4 Kelvin there that we're
getting down to 15 million Kelvin right
and so the refrigeration systems that we
built that that we use they're
commercially available but but it's
phenomenal that you can just turn a turn
hit a button turn a key and cool down
these these devices to such a low
temperature
in the example of the trapped ions if
you want to execute an operation you hit
it with lasers or microwaves what are
you doing your case yeah so in this case
it's more electrically controlled so you
had your place you're placing this chip
inside of this printed circuit board
it's inside of the dilution refrigerator
but then you have all these wires that
come down through the through the
refrigerator and those carry electrical
signals and so to do say a not operation
what we're doing is basically applying a
shaped microwave pulse that's generated
at room temperature so on a set of
electronics that sits outside of the
refrigerator we generated a 5 gigahertz
signal for certain amount of time save
maybe 20 nanoseconds or 30 nanoseconds
that pulse gets sent down into the
refrigerator applies just enough energy
to flip your qubit state from zero to
one okay and then you could do how would
you do a and/or name yeah and then with
regards to two qubit gates so the our
particular architecture connects qubits
on the chip so there's there's other
microwave circuitry that are used to to
to define particular interactions
between qubits on a chip but then those
those interactions are again activated
using microwaves so just the way that we
do the knot we might send we might send
pulses at a slightly different frequency
down into the refrigerator to induce a
two qubit operation such as a
controlled-not gate so everything you've
described is acting on the system so how
does this system act on us to to return
its information and it's the result of
the computation yeah so in the case with
Kathy and they are there they're sending
on another laser beam to do the
detection and you can see it with the
camera but with us what we actually have
to do is is send a another microwave
pulse which is resident with a detection
cavity so there's actually a resonator
on the chip that that that oscillates us
at a slightly different frequency
depending on if the qubit is zero or if
the cupid is one and so we interrogate
this this cavity with with microwave
pulse and at a very low energy level so
single photon energy levels at say six
gigahertz and so that that that signal
goes down into the fridge gets amplified
through various
and then we basically have to digitize
it to determine whether the cubit was a
zero or one cool stuff just to kind of
bring some perspective on the technical
discussion here what would be some pros
and cons of the different techniques why
would you use trapped ions in some cases
superconducting qubits and others well
so pretty much anything at the
microscopic level will compute if you
shine light on it in the right way via
either lasers or microwaves but some
things compute better than others so
what's been happening over the last
decade and a half or so is that the
technologies for for instance
superconducting quantum computing have
really advanced by a lot I mean I was
participated in the early experiments to
build a I think the second
superconducting qubit around 2000 it was
a so-called flux qubit Ben these the
super currents you have a little loop
interrupted by Josephson Junction and so
super current going around forever that
way you call it zero and super current
going around forever that way
counterclockwise sorry clockwise for you
then you call it one and then you know
super current going around both ways
simultaneously both clockwise and
counterclockwise simultaneously that's
zero and one at the same time so that's
how you get a quantum bit in these
things but you would let them sit for a
little while and then you know they'd
get kind of completely randomized very
very rapidly and so these original
superconducting qubits were well they
sucked less space but then there was
this great innovations actually which
participated and I think this was part
of your PhD thesis was developing people
thought oh that the materials are bad
something's wrong with how we're
building these things but it turns out
that it was really much more a kind of a
design issue and buying being really
sneaky about how you design these
systems you could make them much much
much much more coherent so that they
could you know you could have they could
oscillate around or could perform 10,000
logic operations before these things got
messed up and so with superconducting
systems I think that what you did in her
PhD thesis and afterwards some was was a
really amazing innovation and then which
I'll also allow to the
because you're building them on these um
on these chips you can put many of them
together so there's a clear path towards
scalability
um similarly with ion traps the first
ion trap experiments were done in the in
the late nineteen in the mid-1990s um
but they were you know two qubit
experiments sometimes two qubits you can
still do interesting things with two
qubits right you know you can search a
data space with four possibilities and
you can find is it here here here here
by only looking once like how can that
be
classically but we're about to find out
actually yeah so so what's happening is
that there's there's a really there's
been in also with ion traps there have
been all these advances in the
integration and making ion traps larger
and larger integrating them with quantum
communication lines so there's been a
steady advance in in constructing more
and more elaborate and complex quantum
information processors ion traps and
superconducting systems are the two
technologies that are furthest along the
way but there are a whole bunch of other
technologies like nitrogen vacancies in
diamond topological systems and all
kinds of crazy things because again
pretty much anything will compute and
even though as gervais thing that the
twenty cubits okay that doesn't sound
like a lot but two to the twenty is
about a million for two to thirty cubits
to to the 30s about a billion 40 cubits
that's a trillion well you know now
you're starting to try to manipulate
these a trillion numbers of billion or a
trillion numbers and actually that
becomes very difficult classically so
the devices that are being built right
now are just at the threshold where we
actually can't understand what's going
on inside them classically previously we
were able to simulate what was happening
on a huge-mongous classical computer and
phonic trying to figure out what's going
on now we're kind of on our own it's
sort of exploring this quantum frontier
and we you know we we are going to be
able to try to figure out what's going
on them and then with the hope is that
when we build these devices we can use
them to build ever larger devices and
build you know quantum computers that
have a thousand cubits or a million
cubits or a billion cubits so Julia feed
the machines and it's a great moment to
be in historically that machines are now
crossing over and exceeding the
our most powerful classical computer but
then how do we know that they're working
properly if we can't even compare the
result of the calculation of a quantum
computer to a classical computer anymore
and working properly I mean because I
don't know about you know my computer
crashes sometimes I mean how can we
ensure that they're working properly is
maybe a question I can answer
because as you asked what what what
architecture will eventually you know
win don't be the best one and of course
the question we we need to answer is
which one scales best to a large number
of qubits and in theory I'm a
theoretician so I you know I mean I'm in
the position where I write my papers
saying let's assume we have a quantum
computer of 10,000 qubits and then but
there is a lot of theory developed a
theory of say of quantum error
correction for instance where we we face
the fact that no matter how well Katie
Ann and Jerry performed the jobs the
elements out of which they built a
quantum computers will be faulty at some
level there will be a probability that
they'll fail that they'll lose their
coherence and so on and there actually
is a very beautiful theory of quantum
error correction that once we are above
a certain threshold with the noise in
their systems so once the noise is small
enough then we can actually build in
redundancy into these qubits in a way
that the correct the the computation
will perform flawlessly and that's a
very nice theory that will then allow us
to make the quantum computer work at a
larger scale so can fix the mistakes
that can fix the mistakes yes so I think
this might be a good point to talk about
how they actually work and Jerry I know
you've got a demonstration you'd like to
to present to us well first the way that
I want to actually motivate this is is
based off of this this search a search
algorithm and it's a in authority
alluded to this but let's say you have
four cards right and you you you play
the game of Monte right you might go to
a street corner somewhere and put some
money and so out of these four cards
you've got one of them which is
different one of them is a queen and now
now we're gonna flip over and you in
when you play this game you're randomly
gonna try to
find where that where that queen is
right so you you know try once and
you're gonna flip over a carton and see
whether or not it's the Queen and so on
on in playing this game you really only
have a one in four chance of getting it
right on your on your first try but now
what's interesting about this this type
of game is we can also ask well how
would we how would we do this if we had
a computer what what did what does a
class of computer do with this game and
what does a quantum computer to do with
this game okay so in the clays case of a
classical processor what we're doing is
when we when we flip over these cards
you can think of this as as storing a
database in this case where we can also
call it an Oracle so you store the
database with the the hidden set of of
cards where the Queen is is properly
located with the classical computer what
you're gonna do is in order to to find
where it is you're gonna you're gonna
look at all the possible arrangements
right so you're gonna start with one
particular arrangement let's let's start
with placing the Queen in the first slot
and we're gonna take that entry using it
as an input we're gonna do some
processing in this case the green box
where you're gonna do some comparison
with what's in the database and you're
gonna make a decision at the end whether
or not it was correct or not in this
case it was not correct and you get a 0
ok and so now then you can try the next
one
and again you're gonna get a get a 0 and
then the next one and this time you get
a right but of course classically you're
gonna go through all four of them and so
after you go to go through all four you
you see that on average you would have
gotten this correct basically you you
you would get a correct after querying
this database about two and a quarter
times right so this this this problem of
search in this case with the classical
computer you can only kind of do this
sequential sequentially or or by
choosing at random but with the quantum
processor this is where a lot of the
ideas of quantum mechanics can come
through and so the in the next slide
here with with the quantum processor you
have access
- superposition and so just like we
talked about how you can be in 0 and 1
at the same time what you can do with a
two qubit system is to make a
superposition of all four of the
possibilities 0 0 0 1 1 0 and 1 1 to
represent all four of the possible
arrangements of this hidden Queen and so
we can take that superposition state use
it as in as basically as an input call
the database just once
perform some processing step in this
case the processing step involves
entanglement and involves this quantum
interference of adding up adding
together the waves and it'll amplify the
answer for exactly the right answer and
so every time no matter what you what
you place into the database wherever you
hit that card using one call to the
database you get the right answer using
this algorithm and this particular
algorithm is known as Grover's algorithm
and there's a simple case that gives you
the sense for what is done differently
in terms of of processing information on
a classical computer versus a quantum
computer and so on and the next slide
what what you actually would do when you
want a programmer actual quantum quantum
processor is to use this language of
quantum gates and so what you see here
is actually a quantum circuit and as
Seth alluded to the idea of music we
call this actually a score because it
kind of looks like a musical score and
the the concept of time really in time
with gates really has a strong analogy
here because it's like you're playing
different notes on these different
qubits what do you see here is really
just just two of the qubits being
populated with these different
operations which realizes the Grover's
algorithm and to break it down a little
bit further in the in the next slide
what you what you see is that these
various steps of superposition the store
database and the actual post-processing
steps are all are all encoded into these
various gate operations that you can
apply and in this case we can actually
run it through
and and get get a result and I can
actually launch this live please buy own
yeah your why are you switching over
Cathy Ann you were really one of the
first people to actually do this for
real and your dissertation work can you
describe what you accomplished yeah sure
so we did it with trapped ions we had to
trapped ions and as Jerry just showed
that gives you the four element database
and what we did in practice was we had
the computer Marcus state and then we
would run the algorithm similar to the
diagram that Jerry just showed it looks
very similar and then at the end we
would see what the probability was that
we recovered that mark state and at the
time the entangling gate that we used we
were just starting to learn to use it it
had just been demonstrated and so we
found the mark state with a probability
of about 60% but Jerry just told you it
should be a hundred percent and that's
because the the fidelity that's one way
you can measure how good a quantum gate
is the fidelity of our gate wasn't as
high as we would have liked it to be
mostly due to technical difficulties
this isn't a fundamental limit of
trapped ions they sense repeated this
experiment with three qubits recently
and Chris Chris Monroe's group at the
University of Maryland and they did
quite a bit better because the
technology's progressed now at this
point that these gates are are at very
high fidelity
near the fault tolerant levels that
Julia Julia was saying earlier that you
need to run these computers you were
telling me earlier that these so
delicate that you could so much as look
at the laser wrong and it would yeah so
we use cadmium at ions in my graduate
work and they they need laser
frequencies that are about 250
nanometers which is an incredibly
difficult color or light to generate you
basically have to quadruple a laser to
get there so you take a laser you double
it and then you double it again and
doublings hard and the efficiency is low
and one of the people in our lab just
had the right a acoustic sound to his
voice that he would unlock our doubling
cavities and sometimes when he came in
the room he would start to talk and we
were trying to run our experiment and
our laser would shut off very fragile so
here you are you ready to go with this
actually alive
yeah quantum computer yeah I know why I
wanted to start by just showing a little
bit of
the interface of what we have so this is
the IBM Q experience and what we
actually have is a lot of content on
there for anybody to get started with
learning how to program and actually use
a quantum to anybody you can do this
anybody can log in sign up for an
account we have this library with
various user guides for beginners if
you're more familiar with some
mathematics like linear algebra and even
another another guy which actually leads
you to our github developer repository
but through this through this portal you
have access to learning about from the
basics of a qubit superposition
entanglement simple algorithms such as
this this Grover's algorithm and we also
have a community board feature where we
have the ability for anyone to ask
questions and to and our IBM researchers
are more than happy to answer Julie I
wanted to go back to what you're saying
about the factorizing problem that's in
addition to the search algorithm the
other use of that people always talk
about with computers so what's what's
kind of the state of the art in that can
you factor the number fifteen or or get
that high even and you can I mean Jerry
would probably be a better person but
with twenty cubits you can imagine that
you can factor perhaps with some
overhead I would guess you can maybe
factor numbers up to a hundred which of
course you can do in your head so at
this stage we are really at a level
where we demonstrate things when it
comes to factoring the cryptographic
systems that I was talking about that
your credit cards rely on these usually
have something maybe up to a thousand
bits so I think once we get a quantum
computer to the order of perhaps one or
several thousand cubits then you better
stop using your cards with the card
encryption so and well I one thing that
would I would like to mention though
with regards says Shor's algorithm
though is that because of the error
rates that we end up having with the
physical qubits sure if you have a
thousand perfect qubits you might start
thinking about Shor's algorithm for a
thousand
in digit numbers but with with with
needing quantum error correction and a
lot of the best-known encoding you you
have an overhead that significantly
pushes that threshold further so so I
think that in terms of Shor's algorithm
and and a realistic Grover's search
you're thinking about probably needing
billions of tens of millions of cubits
so it's a bit further off but it's still
there was come a day where there come a
day when you got to worry about your
bank accounts but it's the horizon for
that it's a bit further beyond where
we're currently so millions of physical
millions of physical qubits yeah so
definitely maybe around about a few
thousand logical qubits but the the the
the encoding that is what's what's gonna
matter there so Cathy Ann you were
describing also to me earlier that on
the one hand quantum computers take away
our privacy by breaking these codes but
they might also restore can you describe
some worth the work you've done for the
restoration process yeah so there's a
people are working now on in addition to
quantum computing quantum networking and
what you can do with quantum mechanics
for networking and communication the
easiest example to explain it it's been
around for awhile it's called quantum
key distribution where you send a
message between two parties say Alice
and Bob using single photons and because
the photons are encoded using quantum
mechanics you can actually make
protocols that are ultra secure and by
that we mean they're tamper proof
meaning that even if an a an
eavesdropper can't can't get between
Alice and Bob to get the signal because
they don't have the the corresponding
information that was encoded in the
quantum mechanics but even if a nice
topper were to try and grab this signal
the protocols are tamper evident and so
Alice and Bob would see that immediately
when they started to talk about the
results that they got and they would
abandon the protocol so yes it can do
things like break break encryption but
it can also provide ultra secure
protocols so what are you doing the
interweb now to kind of bring that into
fruition so we're working on quantum
networking where instead of sending
key information which that just sends
information to generate a key and then
you
use the key for something else we and a
lot of people in the field are moving
towards quantum networking where you
actually send quantum information
directly over some longer distance link
and so this allows you to do things like
ultra secure communication protocols or
people are also looking at it for
distributed computing or you don't just
have one computer sitting there with
millions let's say of qubits but you
distribute these qubits over a larger
space and you have smaller banks of
qubits
except you once told me this a couple
years ago now remember the anecdote the
NSA funded some early quantum computing
work it's just sure this wasn't possible
because they didn't want to have
unbreakable code oh yeah sorry I was at
the so I back in 1993 I wrote the first
paper showing how you build a quantum
computer using these methods of zapping
stuff with microwaves and lasers and
things like that and then we started to
work with people to build them and in
1994 I the I think the first US
government meeting to fund discuss
funding for quantum computing took place
at DARPA
in um in Arlington and Virginia and and
during this meeting there a bunch of
people including Peter shor were there
talking about stuff and fellow named
stood up and he said I'm Keith Miller
from the NSA and I am authorized to tell
you that the NSA is interested in
quantum computing and then he sat down
again actually told us something that's
incredible cause but it caused such a
stir that he he stood up again and he
said well I believe I'm also authorized
to tell you this of course the NSA is
interested in quantum computing because
our primary mission is to protect the
secrets of the country up to 30 years
for top secrets we have a whole bunch of
information that's out there that's
already encrypted which if someone could
build a quantum computer could be
decrypted and that would be bad
so really are what we would really
prefer is that it not be possible to
build a quantum up by the way this is a
good person to have funding you it's
like you know they call up and they say
how's it going we said oh it's terrible
the qubits are
working everything's taken great great
that's wonderful last very long but then
he said he said but because of our
secondary mission if it is possible we
want to have the first one so to bring
this back down to Morris ideon kind of
applications Jerry you once described to
me some of them will ocular calculations
you were doing um can you walk through
you're doing with these yes so kills so
um I think one of the more kind of
near-term areas that that we'd like to
look at application wise with quantum
computers actually is in in chemical
simulation so what's actually
interesting is that they expect to five
in in around 1980s when he actually
talked about wouldn't it be great to
actually simulate nature using something
that follows the same quantum mechanical
principles of nature and and there's
been a lot of theoretical work going
into how would you actually map say
problems in quantum chemistry for
example electronic and molecular
structure onto physical quantum bits and
it's it's a really neat idea in the
sense that you can you can actually try
and get an analog for a physical or a
real physical system such as the energy
levels of say a hydrogen molecule but
actually run it on a on a on a chip
right run a run that simulation on on
qubit sets that's inside of one of our
dilution refrigerators and so we've our
our team has done various both
theoretical explorations and recently
experimental demonstrations of how to do
some rather simple molecular
calculations so looking at the energy
the ground state energy of a simple
molecule just like hydrogen so two H's
and then lithium hydride beryllium
hydride but very very very small at this
at this at this stage but it shows the
type of trajectory if you will of of
application in the near term because at
some point with these different
alekhya ler structures you get to a
point where there's too many electrons
in it that it's impossible to again
simulate on any class of computer and it
can be rather modest molecular sizes
that that already max out the all the
super super computing resource in the
world and if there's a lot of potential
there for for for quantum computing to
really be a game-changer in that in that
field
Seth was wondering if you could use
merge for me the two great computing
tasks of our time machine learning and
quantum computing relationship um yeah
there for there's the only way to get
information right now as to you know
sorry the only way to get a grant right
now is to apply to do something with big
data and machine learning and then in
physics the only way to get a grant is
to do something with graphene so the
material of the future along with
gallium arsenide and so the real reason
is just have something so you can have a
grant this you know graphene-based
quantum random access memories for the
analysis of big data it's it's a winner
I guarantee so um it's interesting now
that we are we actually are about to
have simple quantum computers that have
you know tens of qubits and say 50
cubits coming up and I think that
there's a reasonable path to think of
having up to a thousand physical to bits
over the next five to ten years I don't
think that's an unreasonable to expect
what will you do with these devices now
because they are quantum mechanical and
they're very hard to simulate
classically mr. er was saying they are
they quantum mechanics you know it's
famously weird and funky and quantum
systems exhibit funky and strange
effects like entanglement
einstein-podolsky-rosen correlations and
Schrodinger's cats and um statistical
patterns in data that are very hard to
capture classically they're
counterintuitive it's hard for classical
computers to capture them so if they can
exhibit these if quantum systems can
generate these funky patterns that you
can't generate classically
maybe they can also recognize patterns
that you can't recognize classically the
machine learning is about taking
patterns and data and trying to tease
them out and show that they're there
it's a recognizing patterns and data
machine learning is course very trendy
right now justifiably so not not really
because actually I think you know it's
about to supplant human beings or
anything like that but because actually
Scott and good you know there's this uh
there's this thing called deep learning
which one I learned about it of three or
four years ago I said wow this is
fantastic you know computers will tell
us about love and truth and you know
happiness and all this deep stuff but no
such luck it turns out that these are
just neural electronic analogs of neural
circuitry that have many many many many
levels in it so they're deep in that
sense but they actually do do problems
they solve problems that are hard to do
now if you get inside a machine learning
algorithm like say the Netflix algorithm
where you know you say okay what shall i
watched it am Netflix as well I think
that you would like to see Dirty Harry
but I know I for some reason my students
don't watch Clint Eastwood any longer I
don't know what it is you know they what
what Netflix is doing is they're
actually looking at the Preferences of
everybody out there who's looking at
Netflix comparing your preferences for
their to theirs and then you know doing
what's called a matrix completion
algorithm to recommend something to you
now if you were to program that in a
co-op into a quantum computer it turns
out that their algorithm which they only
run they run it twice a day because it's
so incredibly computationally intensive
that if you do that on quantum computer
you could have a quantum computer that
had say a hundred quantum bits and you
could do ten thousand operations and it
would do the same set of operations in a
quantum mechanical fashion so we decided
hey we've this is great we'll call this
the quantum net flix algorithm but then
I googled quantum net flix algorithm it
turns out that Netflix calls their own
algorithm the quantum algorithm even
nothing whatsoever to do so using you
know quantum computers quantum systems
in general exhibit strange encounter to
of intuitive patterns this gives you
reason to hope that they can recognize
strange patterns and it turns out that
the actual stuff that they're doing
already for things like factoring
verse is great for actually finding
patterns in data and actually this is a
nice application that people have been
using to demonstrate you know simple
versions of these algorithms on small
quantum computers obviously the world as
we know it would not be the same without
computers they're just everywhere
they're ubiquitous well well 50 years
from now people say the same thing about
quantum computers will they be as
transformative as classical computers
have been that's an excellent question
I view I think a quantum computer will
remain it might be ubiquitous but it
will remain a special purpose device for
various things I don't think it will
replace the computers as we know them in
its entirety so I view the future
perhaps as you have in your laptop and
then a little bangle with one of Jerry's
or Katie Ann's contraptions and then
whenever you you know whenever you need
to break into somebody else's credit
card or whatever it is that you want to
do you make you know you may cost that
you know - that's a special device I
think that's that's more likely picture
of the future with the quantum computer
in it then yeah so it's more like a GPU
inside of a xbox yeah thing I guess than
a yes there won't be a literally quantum
iPhone a little Apple may trademark well
I'm more optimistic I think you know if
you build it they will come
right so once we have quantum computers
to play around which you already do
thanks to IBM and over the net people
will play around and we'll come up with
you know more quantum apps claps claps
for all did you frame mark that I trade
mark the cloud with a cue questions so
the four card monte example I mean it's
it looks to me like something that's
could basically like backwards solve any
kind of cryptographic hash like as a
black box for whatever the hash is and
yet I hear about these these quantum
proof cryptographic methods and because
it seems like it doesn't matter what the
actual hash operations
or how does that like what is the
general underlying principle for these
quantum proof hash hash hash functions
so a hash function in cryptography is a
function - just like scrambles
everything up in a way where you can
check to see if it's been scrambled up
in the proper fashion and inverting
these so undoing this hashing is
supposed to be hard as the basis for a
lot of cryptographic protocols it's
still hard on a quantum computer that is
this quantum searching will allow you to
get a speed-up - that will allow you to
you know solve some problems that you
would be able to solve classically but
this kind of hashing problem is still
hard on a quantum computer so one of the
things that's going on right now because
exactly because quantum computers are
getting more powerful though let's face
it we're still you know we we can
basically compute our way out of a paper
bag now previously we couldn't compute
our way out of a paper bag so but you
know even the at the NSA has issued an
advisory saying you know if you're going
to come up with an application that's
gonna supposed to still be secure 20
years down the line it's time for you to
think of something in addition because
quantum computers might be there so
people are coming to try to come up with
what's called post quantum cryptography
and I think that you're alluding to some
of these problems there now you make me
wonder what post quantum cryptography
could possibly be just give up oh so
based on a so public key cryptography is
a way where you know I send uh suppose I
so I buy green coffee beans over the
internet and then roast them at home so
what you actually do yes I do absolute
so much but so much fresh when I do this
when I like say try to send by something
from sweet Maria's and Berkeley you know
this 10 pounds of Costa Rican then sweet
Maria sends me a big number which is a
product of two smaller numbers which are
prime numbers and this is called the
public key this big number I could use
that number to encrypt my information in
a way such that only sweet Maria who
knows the two smaller numbers can
decrypt it and that's the basis for
public key
Photography there's a public key which
is what they send out there anybody can
encrypt but to decrypt you need to know
the private key the these two numbers
this is what quanta computers can do if
they can find the private key given the
public key which would be very
disruptive than because I frankly I like
my freshly roasted green coffee and I
would be pretty pissed off if I couldn't
get it so and so so the idea is to you
see this as a rather specific protocol
and so what people are trying to come up
with are other protocols where quantum
computers can't break those protocols
where there's a public key you can
encrypt using the public key but then
you can only decrypt using the private
key but a quantum computer can't find
the private key and so far there's been
mixed success I would say about doing
this there's not nothing's ready for
primetime I mean yeah yeah I should say
I mean this is also important because
even though quantum computer is not
there you might want to encode your
information in a way that nobody can
decode it in the next 100 years and 100
years is a very long time right and then
we might assume a quantum computer could
be there I mean a big one and the post
refers to the fact that even though you
encrypted today maybe you you don't want
it to be decrypted in you know 95 years
by one of you know the successors of
Jerry's computers and there are there
are methods nowadays in fact that
cryptographers have started to develop
but they are extremely impractical at
this that the public keys you would have
to transmit are so long that it would
take you you know hours basically to do
that but it's it's it will be wrong to
say that there is an alternative but
it's not a practical alternative more
questions I sold a bunch how does the
observer effect plan to like retrieving
information would collapse right like it
would just collapse back to two bits
so like how do you maintain like the
four bits or whatever yeah yeah so it's
it's observing it as is act is is
essential to how we actually make use of
a quantum computer right because it has
to be something tangible that we can put
in there has to be something tangible
that we can take out so the input will
be classical bits the outflow be
classical bits
in between is where we make use of
superposition entanglement and this 2 to
the N exponential space state space and
the key thing is how is how do you
tailor your algorithm to make use of
that so that when you perform that
measurement you've learned something
that you otherwise wouldn't have had
wouldn't have been able to calculate so
it's all about how you define those
interferences of the waves through the
operations you perform in between you
only observe at the end before that it's
considered to be rude to look at
somebody's clawed a computer well it's
an operation so that that's part of the
difficulty in controlling these very
complex systems is because if you make a
measurement or if the environment makes
a measurement without your knowledge the
same thing happens and so you have to
control the system very well so that you
only look or the environment only
measures a system at the end of the
computation so it sounds like a lot of
the stuff that you guys are working on
is kind of like a straight analogy from
a classical computer to a quantum
computer or like a bit as a qubit and
you're working with seen on kids I was
wondering if you could talk about how um
quantum annealer is like what do you
wave works on how what you guys work on
factors into that and if there are any
sort of limitations using the annealing
paradigm I know that that's usually
better off for like combinatorial
optimization problems but is there any
other sort of limitation on what a
kneeler can do versus what a straight
quantum computer could do well I think
the the first thing there's just an
annealer is a is a very it's a more
restricted type of problem right so
you've your your hardware it the way
that you lay down these the circuits in
an annealer you've defined all the
couplings between these these these
these devices and you have defined a
particular energy landscape that you
want to say optimize or or find the
ground state for in the case with with
the systems are we're building where you
have full quantum control over any of
the the qubits you really can drive the
system to any kind of quantum quantum
problem that you want and so it's it's
reprogrammable in that sense right and
it and
and you can define your optimization
landscape in in in in more generality
but maybe set you can also comment on
the d-wave yeah I mean yeah also let me
say say that that you keep on letting
people who possess prior knowledge into
this room which makes our lives harder
so what's that about so um here so
quantum annealer as as Jerry was saying
it's um it's actually very an old idea
classically there's a notion called
simulated annealing classically where
you want to solve a hard problem so you
want to to find you know the the minimum
value of some function and many problems
are like this like the Traveling
Salesman problem I want to find the
shortest path will get me through all
the cities in the United States and back
to where I started that's a hard problem
and so what you do is you map this
problem into finding the lowest energy
state of a physical system and then you
try to find this lowest energy state by
cooling annealing that's why it's called
annealing um to get down to this this
lowest energy State
now quantum annealing is a sneaky trick
that does this quantum mechanically you
construct a quantum system I mean for
instance system d-wave quantum annealer
is a tunable device with up to a couple
thousand quantum bits and they can tune
all the couplings between them and then
you set it up so that the lowest energy
state encodes the answer to your problem
and then you try to find this lowest
energy state by kind of oozing in a
funky quantum mechanical state off the
fashion from some known state into this
unknown state and either it works or it
doesn't
now it's an interesting situation
because actually nobody knows if this
works is supposed to work
even in theory and so it's one of these
things where if you build it and then
you see what happens they find that some
fraction of the time they actually get
the right answer there's a lot of
argument about whether this is happening
in an intrinsically quantum mechanical
way or not but I mean these are very
interesting systems I mean d-wave
deserves great credit for building a
large-scale quantum system it's got lots
of entanglement in it it's got you know
it's it's has thousands of quantum bits
and it's actually a beautiful system
just for doing experiments on I'm going
to a conference in Japan next week where
or two weeks from now where basically
people are going to report on all the
experiments that they're doing on these
different D wave devices to try to
figure out what the heck is going on I'm
afraid I'm gonna have to call the
collections there
you
[Music]